and ATM stolen out of the store and all
right we got a question for you would
this make you feel safe take a look a
security guard armed with a
semi-automatic weapon it's happening at
a North Philly gas station the owner
coming up with the idea to scare off
criminals if you saw this this is our go
vote for tonight would you feel safer or
uncomfortable safe safe next topic safe
safe
safe you know what's happening in Philly
if that's the gas station I'm going in
yeah safe you can get your car robbed
about this [ __ ] if you ain't got nothing
if that's the if that's the guard that
he's waiting there safe
baseball safe hey you already
yo I want you guys to understand the
monster I was on a date a while back and
I remember I was talking to a girl yeah
and she said she was into guns
really into it and I I popped the
biggest boner you know I'm saying up in
Canada especially you you don't get to
be talking about stuff like that with
too many people who approved so you want
to know what I think in places where
it's dangerous I approve there's no
reason I should be going to a gas
station and the [ __ ] feel that
dangerous but guess what in some places
women can't even get out their car to go
to gas station because they know it's
dangerous and in some places I wouldn't
even try to get out my car
Lamar you walk in that [ __ ] you feel it
and also forget what we feel a lot of
these places get robbed they get stuck
up a lot they get vandalized or they
have crazy people roll through all the
time yeah listen not every place is safe
if you lived inside our safety the
people were saying uncomfortable are the
people who generally don't live in those
areas or they don't know nothing about
guns
a gun made them feel comfortable because
the only time that they see a gun is in
store is in movies so seeing one and
real is like huh it's something listen I
went if you and most [ __ ] don't
travel the world all right most of you
that are not comfortable travel the
world I remember I was at the beach one
day and there was a beach in Cuba right
and everything was all good and dandy
and everything was fresh and we were
going back to our our hotel rooms and
stuff like that and at night I decided
to take a walk with my girl and what do
I see I see a god with a gun staring at
the ocean absolutely and at the other
end at the other end of the the the the
Playa Papa there was another God
standing with a gun like that looking at
the ocean
thank you for your service
because you know there's some people are
going to come up in here and rap like
like run through the thing and then
steal a bunch of people Pirates of the
Caribbean is just it's not just a movie
you understand what I'm saying so yeah
I've been to Haiti gas bombs they
standing here with a 12 siding they were
just waiting if Ping Pop off miyago Papa
first yeah here but that's Haiti that's
not America listen in some places in
America it's Haiti and some places in
Haiti is America so stop stop playing
stop playing I've seen it I've seen both
I've seen both in both places so stop
talking [ __ ] so if I see that at the gas
station to me that's just that's just
the gun at the gas station there's a
reason for that and I don't I don't feel
bad because you know you know damn well
I'm a Canadian and I cannot have a gun
in the states yet
okay and I cannot protect myself like
that but if something happened and
something was about to pop off
[ __ ] are gonna try they're
gonna think twice hey low-key low-key
twice Hey listen before you run up on
that gas station
listen people say this oh okay Canada so
save this uh listen you saw that
pandemic grow through and [ __ ]
lost their mind over toilet paper I'm
not doing it for when times are safe I'm
thinking about it when times are not the
greatest Society is it takes one really
bad winner sir it takes one pendant and
all you realize is this whole [ __ ] is
fickle two weeks
it took number two weeks and people was
swinging for toilet paper not even so
imagine when it's real this is just from
the consumer standpoint think about it
from the business owner's standpoint if
they feel they need to make that kind of
financial investment it means that it
costs them too much to not have that
security because no [ __ ] gas station
owner is going to cut into their profits
to hire security guard for the [ __ ]
shits and giggles they hire it because
their place getting [ __ ] up on a
regular another reason that's a reason
that much money now I hope the security
guards are well trained to be able to
handle these Farms that's always really
really important but he's not paying for
the this because it's cute he's doing it
because it's financially necessary so
right now the vote is 65 percent of you
saying safer 35 percent uncomfortable so
be sure to vote at fox29.com go vote
Shawnette you spoke with the gas station
owner who says this is needed to keep
both his workers and customers safe the
store manager says that he had to do
something more than call 9-1-1 and most
customers I'll tell you that I talked to
this evening on and off camera say that
they support this but there were a few
who say they don't believe this is the
right approach let me tell you something
that's the thing that happened you tell
and that that's a good point that she
wrote
people always tell me that yeah but you
know when there's a problem you just
have to call 9-1-1
when in your life has Cops prevented
something from happening in your life
I'm not saying that they don't prevent
things from happening they do but in
your life for example a robbery you got
your car Rob or you got your house uh
rod and stuff like that when you call
them after the fact
and knowing from the fact when you call
them after the fact they don't come
right away
yeah it happened it happened when it
happened to me in the city city we got
robbed it took three hours and a half
for the cops to show up because they got
other [ __ ] to do
they got other things to take care of
the cops often come
after the fact and they're not gonna go
look for no robbers
but sometimes a livelihood is taking it
you feel so unsafe when you know
someone's been going through your stuff
been going through your things you don't
know what they have what they have for
information what they hold or if they're
going to come back because they know
yo hired security strapped with AR-15s
or shotguns standing guard and walking
the property of this North Philly gas
station and convenience store this is
supposed to be a city right
and you got your kids walking around
guns like this would be on the
battlefield he said you got the kids Hey
listen let's keep it a stack some of
these kids are doing the robin and and
if your kids outside at 11
and also let's be honest your kids are
probably seeing those things on the
street anyways oh yeah depending on
where you at anything first time Rory
Barry says she's on board with it if
you're trying to get gas you live in a
bad area and the only place is here and
they're getting robbed all the time I
mean I support the owner Neil Patel is
the manager of this carco shop franchise
at Broad and Clearfield we are tired
from this all nonsense robbery drug
trafficking track of things all kind of
hanging around you all gangs he shared
with me these videos of what has led up
to this drastic response to Crime at his
business over the past few weeks he says
his store was Trashed by young people
and ATM stolen out of the store and he
says his car was gay
yo they just walked out with the whole
ATM
no and by the time by the time you call
the ATM and then they track down the ATM
the GPS is already gone that [ __ ] that
thing is already sliced up and the
money's out the bag my dude come on my
dude
they just took out the whole ATM a whole
ATM this gives a whole new definition to
withdrawal armed robbery no they
withdrew they just withdrew the ATL the
whole [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] they said
enter your pit he said enter these nuts
give me the whole thing that's a lot
yeah but I can understand because
sometimes you know sometimes when you go
to the ATM they tell you hey uh
hide your PIN number because you know
there might be some robbers and then you
charge me five dollars to get my own
money out of my account you're the
robbers know how you got robbed You're
like give me my five dollars back you
just took the eight yeah
[Music]
ATMs that were just kind of like no name
brands or whatever
they they they they hey wait is that
your pocket bruh yeah let me just get in
there
yeah
just let you know too they put a little
oh you want to draw money well there's a
three dollar fee by the way your bank
might also charge you yeah
and sometimes and sometimes sometimes
they give you uh uh three dollars per
slices of a hundred yeah so if you if
you withdraw 400 they're like oh oh
my God feeling really good is gonna cost
you something
oh you just got it oh it's a Payday for
you yeah it's payday for me too all
right listen I know like you guys
probably think yo I've been preach you
guys make money now yeah but I still
think no no no no no no no no
there is they don't care there is not
and and there's not enough money that
would get in my bank account that it
would not piss me off to get charged
sometimes I went bruv I just came back
from Vegas yeah there was a whole ass
ATM because they know the [ __ ]
want money you know how much the thing
was yeah 12 bucks
for 200 . the sickness
we don't want it we don't want it rub
the ATM ticket tour oh yeah but please
leave this start hey
they're forcing us to
hire the security high level security
state level I am fearful by safety of my
employee as well as my nice neighborhood
people realize like oh oh wait this is
not this is not my neighborhood this is
somewhere else this is Africa
okay it wasn't African but there's a lot
of black people
Andre Boyer is the chief of the company
as a Pennsylvania state agent that's
what it says the law tells us that we
have a right to protect this property in
the any means necessary and whatever
Force necessary to be used to protect it
this man told employees he's against it
I asked Patel about it they feel like
using guns you know when we have such a
big problem with guns in the city is is
not the right message and that's not a
nice way I understand that but according
to the some people violent people they
carry the gun then they're not afraid
then and this is the protection for a
neighborhood and the customers
all right so you heard him he just said
that uh people who are against this are
concerned about the armed security but
they should be concerned about the bad
guys who are out there carrying the guns
meanwhile Patel says that he's had a
store there for about 20 years he said
the crime has gotten increasingly worse
just over the past few years and he
tells me that in the past three weeks he
hasn't had any issues with the crime
since bringing this company on and the
people you talk to seanette I have this
out on Twitter this is where we are in
the city this is unfortunately uh what
we need to do to keep our stores and our
customers safe if we own a gas station
and especially since you see everything
that happened with this particular
business owner seanette I just want to
mention too just going back to our go
vote when we came on the air I think it
was around 65 percent who said that it
makes them feel safer now it's at 80
percent just during your report yeah
yeah Hey listen man like this place I've
been to I'm like y'all don't need this
[ __ ] you know I mean there's certain
neighborhoods I've been towards like
this is not necessary you can feel it
you you you you know the difference okay
but in some places I've been to I'm like
hell yeah cops are already over flooded
with things that they have to hang the
idea that you want to put your safety in
someone else's hands like I'm not so
happy to see that these guys are really
well trained they have to constantly
re-up on that training yeah that's
already more than some police
departments you feel me so as far as
feeling safe ghosts got to give them
some credit if they really are doing the
weapon stream that they're claiming when
it comes to this stuff now it does make
me a little antsy if you're thinking
about like bullets flying near a gas
station you know what I mean I don't
know how gas stations work or is it
still like if you fire a bullet at the
thing does it stop that's Hollywood
that's Hollywood that's Hollywood and
there's always safety things safety
measure that you can cut off the but
it's just like firing at a car it's not
gonna explode the whole thing about like
having a lighter and using that near the
thing is not that's fumes okay so that's
dangerous well while you're pumping is
one thing if you're not pumping that's
another thing you know I mean but in
fact it's not like you have Tracer
bullets in your gun anyways like you
have to if you know in what kind of
environment you are like he's working
around a fire station so he's not
necessarily gonna have Tracer bullets in
this [ __ ] thing so the thing is gonna
light up and then it's gonna cause a
fire you look at the guys you know what
I mean she look at the guy's Arsenal and
for some reason this [ __ ] just got a
frag grenade frag grenade Tracer that's
not what we're doing
[Laughter]
well this is at least it's neutralized
yeah but you nuked the whole place like
everybody all right but anyways let us
know what you guys think
that's not the void